[Music]
some 22 million americans lost their
jobs in march
and april after the pandemic hit this
country about half of them have been
rehired or gotten new jobs
but many others are still struggling for
new roles in a
very tough job market here are some of
their stories
for work i was an event coordinator i
have been a bartender for 10 years
i thought my job was very safe it was
the hospital industry
i was a flight attendant for six years
it's announced that
you know everything's closing now it's
affecting everything of like how am i
gonna survive
i kind of decided that maybe it was time
for me to
kind of move on and i'm just working on
building my drone photography business
i got on linkedin i got on instagram i
got on facebook
and just started looking for
opportunities we've been working with
the same company for 20 years so it's a
whole new experience to be in the job
market
i decided to go ahead and officially
make the career change
but i have to say i'm finally thriving i
do real estate full time now
i think the anxiety of you
failing when the world has stopped
kind of goes away because you're just
like well everybody else is in the same
position
we gotta remember this is not forever
but this is the opportunity to come back
with more passion and more like less for
life i think
steven and jenna have transitioned into
new careers but like many people scott
and christina
are still looking for the right job a
new survey out this morning from
linkedin reveals
84 percent of people who lost jobs in
the pandemic
say there is a negative stigma to being
unemployed and 67
percent believe that that stigma affects
their ability to be hired
linkedin editor-in-chief dan roth joins
us now with the tales of this survey
that you'll hear first on cbs this
morning dan welcome nice to see you
um this is a really tough time this is a
really tough time for people as we saw
we heard
scott who's been in the same company 20
years i feel like he's got a whole new
experience
you surveyed 2 000 people who
lost their jobs during the pandemic how
are those folks feeling right now
well the number one thing that they're
feeling is is fear and anxiety which of
course
you are if you don't have a job right
now and i think
then if you look deeper into the numbers
the other things they're feeling are
embarrassment
and they're ashamed of not having a job
and an amazing 46 percent said they have
lied
about being unemployed there is this
stigma
that being unemployed that looking for
work is something to be embarrassed
about that it's going to hurt you
and i think if there's one takeaway from
the survey it's that that stigma is
unfounded
that that is not something that is true
people do not mind if you are unemployed
yeah dan i'm surprised at that because
because with so many people going
through this at the same time and it's
obviously
it's it's it's nobody's fault it's just
what happened i i the embarrassment
surprised me i thought there would be
some comfort in knowing that so many
others were going through it
well i think that we've all heard that
added you know that you the best way to
find a job is by having a job and i
think there is this sense that i've got
to keep working i'm only going to get
i'm only going to get my next job if i
if i'm already currently employed but we
we talked as part of that survey we
talked to hiring managers 96
of hiring managers said they would hire
someone who was unemployed
so that stigma is something we put on
ourselves that doesn't have to be there
yeah what are the hiring managers
looking for right now
uh well number one they're looking for
skills they want to show that they want
to see that you
have a that you have the skills that
they need for these jobs they want to
see resourcefulness
so just showing that you're doing
something even if you don't have
work if you are gaining skills if you
are
taking classes if you are volunteering
places all of those are really important
you have to show that you are
doing something with your time so being
able to explain it
and then you need to show what you are
how you think and i think a lot of
hiring managers they want to make sure
they're hiring the best candidates
they look at your profile they see where
you've worked that's important they look
at your skills but they want to know
what's going on in your head and so
the more you're posting the more you're
talking about what you are
what you're good at what you've learned
how you think that all gives them a
sense of what you're going to be like
in the workplace so they want to see
that you are about 48
said they look at public posts to make a
determination of whether this is someone
they want to bring in
quickly dan if you're if you're in one
of those hard-hit industries aviation
hospitality
how do you make a pivot at this point
uh number one know what your skills are
don't be make sure that you understand
what you're good at so one of my
favorite
examples is of of these transferable
skills is
i talked to an insurance company at one
point they said that when they are
trying to hire insurance adjusters they
try to hire bartenders because
bartenders have a skill of getting
people to tell stories
so you have these skills know what your
skills are build those skills
make sure that you're that you're out
there dan roth thank you so much